the countdown is on to resorts world las
vegas grand opening tomorrow night
you will be able to check out the city's
very newest resort joe moeller toured
the property today
he gives us a sneak peek
we are one day away from resorts world's
grand opening here on the las
vegas strip from the technology to the
food resorts world
is bringing several new experiences to
the strip the 4 billion dollar resort
mixes luxury with modern technology
in the casino you can place bets through
a mobile app when you sit down at a
table
something not done at a casino on a
strip the food options
are endless with street food options
from around the world to new restaurants
i sat down with billy richardson the
owner of marigold lobster and burgers
a new american restaurant he says it's
nice to see a resort opening at a time
like this
we're super excited to be here it's
after everything that we've gone through
it's great that vegas is opening up a
new big building so
you know when we open these buildings in
town it draws a lot of attention and
and that's what we need we need we want
people to come here and enjoy
there are three brands inside resorts
world hilton crockfords and conrad
each has their own lobby the resort also
has nine pools filled with a number of
places to eat and get drinks
the work isn't done yet the day club and
nightclub won't open until next week as
several shows are planned for july 4th
weekend
despite work still being done on the
outside of resorts world the plan is to
open to the public tomorrow at 11 pm
after a private party reporting on the
las vegas strip joe muller 8 news now
all right joe thanks for that resorts
world also making changes to food
delivery hotel pool guests will be able
to use grub hub
to order food right to their location